- Welcome back, guys.
Today I'm back in Munich,
at the day of recording.
It's the 31st December of this year,
so the last day of the new year.
Today with my wife, today
I'm just going in the city,
getting my last stuff
ready for New Year's Eve.
We are very much looking forward.
But today, I wanna
fulfill a promise to you.
Because if you have seen
my last video on the goals
for the new year, you know
that one of my main goals
is also to keep my
personal finances healthy.
And a big important part
of that is my net worth.
And I received many
comments from you guys,
asking me to share this
net worth tracker of mine.
How I do this, what my system
is, to keep this in order.
So today I'm going to do exactly that.
I do think it can be
a life-changing video.
I know this is quite a bold
claim, but nevertheless,
I believe this is what was
the case for me when I started
a couple of years ago, to do
this in this systematic way.
So welcome back to another coffee break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and on my channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I'm a former McKinsey consultant,
and I talk about all things
management, career consulting.
But I do wanna help you to
get your personal finances
in order as well.
So without further ado,
let's jump into it.
I will show you the tool that I use
for myself to track my net worth.
And yes, in the very end of the video,
I will show you an option
where you can actually
download the tool for
yourself, for your use.
So if you find this
helpful, watch until the end
to see this donor options way.
I'm back home now
and I have my notebook
here in front of me,
so I will now look down here, on the PC.
And what you see here is
already the full version
of the net worth tracking
sheet that I was talking about.
And don't be discouraged,
this might look a bit
complicated and crazy at first,
and I will break it down for you,
I will simplify it for you.
What you see here is
now a version for 2020,
and then on the right already
extended it for the next year.
Just to show you how then you could also
continue to track all
of this going forward.
Now to simplify it and
to go over it in detail,
let me just close this down.
Group this together,
and now just zoom in
here on the 2020 part.
You see that there are already
some numbers here filled
for 2020, just two important remarks.
So first of all, these are
of course, not my numbers,
I pretty much made all these numbers up.
And second, let's please
now not talk about
whether these numbers
are too high or too low,
are realistic or not.
This is not about the
specific numbers that you see
but it's rather about
the overall methodology,
the overall logic of tracking all of this.
So you see that there are two parts here.
The upper part that tracks the net worth,
and then the lower part
that tracks the cashflow.
In the strict sense, the only
thing that's really relevant
for your net worth is this upper part.
Though I do believe that
for your personal finances,
it is important to get an
understanding of your cashflow.
So your income and your expenses as well.
So let's start with the net worth.
What is actually your net worth?
And the answer to that is
that the net worth is the
difference between your assets
and your liabilities.
Now we are going to look together
into what exactly this means.
But the net worth pretty much
is how rich you are, right.
What is the value of all your holdings?
What is the value
of everything that you
have against your name?
So again, looking back into
this sheet, you can see
that it takes as a formula,
the sum of your assets,
and it subtracts the
sum of your liabilities.
So this is here, what the net worth is.
And then the growth is just tracking
the percentage difference, month on month.
So let's look into these two areas,
assets and liabilities, in detail.
Let's start with the assets.
So what you see here now
is a structure of assets
that probably works for many people.
But of course,
if now you track this for
yourself, just ask yourself,
what are the assets that you actually own?
And then of course, feel
free to delete whole sections
or maybe even add additional sections
if you feel like the
specific assets that you own
do not really fit in
to this scheme, right.
But this is just something
that I believe is
generally applicable and
works for many people.
So let's start with your deposits.
So this is just the accounts, the accounts
with banks or any other
accounts that you hold,
they pretty much have cash on them.
So in this example here, there
are two checking accounts.
One at the Deutsche Bank,
one at the Commerzbank.
Then there is a savings account and then
you might have some money on your PayPal.
Again, you might have more accounts,
you might have fewer accounts.
Just insert every account in a line,
and then just track every month
how much money you have on it.
What I personally do not
track is the cash that I have
with me at any point in time.
So this would of course, be
part of your net worth as well.
Personally, I receive this
as a little extra that I have
and I will not specifically
track this here.
So far, so good.
Let's look into the next
section, financial instruments.
And here you can pretty
much add all the stocks,
all the ETFs, all the funds,
all these securities that you own.
What exactly this is and
how many different positions
you have, of course can depend.
So if you are interested
how I specifically think
about this whole investment
topic, I made a whole video
about investments for young professionals.
I will link it somewhere above here.
So have a look if this
is of value for you.
Of course, I need to make
the overall disclaimer
that this is not investment advice,
I'm not an investment professional.
So please do your own research
before investing in anything.
Next, is real estate.
And maybe you are lucky
or successful enough to
own some real estate.
Maybe some apartments or even full houses,
then I would add each object that you hold
in a separate line and then
add the value of that object
in the different columns.
With assets like this, I would in general,
assume that the value stays
rather constant over time.
And then probably every year or so,
you can just look into it
and then potentially make
some adjustments as necessary.
Of course now, if you
purchase real estate,
you often take a loan, a
mortgage to finance that.
And this is what will come
into play in the liability section.
So we're going to talk about
that in a moment as well.
Next, digital assets.
Maybe you own some digital
assets like Bitcoin.
Again, no financial
advice, no recommendation,
you do your own research.
But here as well, you could
add each asset that you own
in the lines and then track the value.
Personally, I'm quite passionate
about digital assets and
blockchain technology.
I made a full video course explaining what
blockchain technology is
all about and how it works.
Also, how it can be used
in the business world
with different use cases.
So if you're interested
in this video course,
check out the video
description below to the link
to this mini course of mine.
Next, commodities.
So maybe you own some
physical commodities,
for instance, gold or silver.
Some gold coins or anything like that.
Here again, you can track the value
and then I would recommend
you to every half a year,
or every year or so, just
look into the figures,
update it according to
the current market value.
Next, additional objects of value.
So the classical example
here would be a car.
Or maybe you also own an expensive watch
or an expensive piece of
art or anything like that.
This could be the place
where you list these objects.
Here of course, be careful
that you do not fool yourself.
So general or consumer
products that you own
or expensive pieces of clothing,
all of this I would not list
here, even if you might be able
to get some money for
it if you would sell it.
Often the actual market value
of these objects would
be significantly smaller
than what you might believe it is.
So as a best practice,
I would just not include these things.
Treat them as a little
buffer that you have
if things go really south.
And only include things
where you really know
that they will have a
significant market value.
And this is of course
true for cars as well.
The problem with cars is that the value
will go down rapidly over time.
So make sure that you
update the value of your car
if you want to list it here at
all, every half a year or so,
just to make sure that
you're not fooling yourself.
So the next section in your
assets are your receivables.
So again, some people might
not have anything like this.
A receivable could for
instance be an expense claim.
So what I mean by that,
that when I was in
consulting, I was pretty lazy.
And I only handed in my expenses
every couple of months or so, which meant
that my expense claims at the
time had at least four digits.
Let's just put it this way, guys.
So of course, this is
a claim that you have,
this is a receivable that you have,
and this might be something
that you want to list
in such an overview as well.
Of course, up to the moment
when then you get the money,
as for instance here in
this example in April,
well then the expense
claim would go to zero.
But then of course you will have the cash
on one of your accounts
listed here somewhere above.
And then another
receivable might be a loan
that you are giving to somebody else.
So maybe you wanna help out a
family member or a colleague
or a friend of yours, and you
decided to give them a loan.
And then of course the value
of the principle of that
loan would be an asset,
a receivable for you as well.
Of course, assuming
that you can have the
reasonable expectation
that this will be paid back
to you at some point in time.
So this is the overview of the assets.
Again, this can look very different
for your specific situation.
Of course, adapt this
to your specific needs,
to the asset classes that you own,
but this is the overall idea.
So I am currently here in the kitchen,
we are getting ourselves ready
for a nice little New Year's Eve dinner.
Only the two of us, my wife and I.
So I hope though, that this video
inspired you to start your
investment game as well,
if it did not start yet.
And there are two services
that I can recommend for you.
So if you live in the US, there is Webull.
And if you actually sign up there
via the link in the video
description, I believe
at the moment they give you
even up to four free stocks,
so just for signing up.
So have a look at that,
and then for the German speaking people
there is Trade Republic.
This is also a service
where they have almost
no fees at all for investing
in stocks, in ETFs.
Again, link in the video description.
Check it out if this interests for you.
But now let's look into
the liabilities as well.
For the liabilities, I
have three categories
that now I want to talk about today.
The first is the consumer debt.
Probably the most common example
of consumer debt is the open
balance on your credit cards.
So at the time when you update
this every single month,
just look into your credit cards
and see what the open balance
of your cards is at that
specific point in time.
And then this open balance
that you still owe,
this is the amount that
you should include here.
Of course, if you have
any other consumer loans,
any other consumer debt, this
is what you could include
in additional lines here as well.
Regarding consumer debt,
of course, I trust I
do not need to tell you
that this really should be avoided.
If you just use a credit
card as a means of payment
and then just pay off the balance
at the end of every month.
But do not just start buying things
on credit that you actually
cannot afford at the moment,
just with the perspective of
hopefully paying for later
at any point in time.
Next is the real estate debt.
So in this example where you
own these two apartments in Dusseldorf,
there might still be a
certain amount that you owe
towards these apartments.
And this is then of course,
the debt that you have if
you financed it via loan.
So yeah, make sure that
you track every month
what the open balance is
on these loans, in order to
correctly show the picture
here of your personal finances.
Now another type of debt,
that now I don't have in this example
but that you could also add
are of course, student loans.
So if you have student loans,
which still have an open balance
of course, then list this
as an additional line item
within your liabilities as well.
And the last point I wanna talk
about regarding liabilities
are the accrued taxes.
So this would probably not be so relevant
if you are an employee.
But if you're self employed,
of course, you do not
have an employer who
directly deducts income taxes
from your paycheck, but you
often need to pay the income tax
at the end of the year.
And depending on the
size of your business,
this can sum up to a
very significant amount.
So if you're self employed, make sure
that you have a good understanding
of what your tax obligations
will be at the end of the year.
And then of course, in such an overview,
make sure that you also
track what the current
sum of the tax obligations
in the current year is.
Because of course, this
needs to be deducted
to then get to your net worth.
So that's it guys, this is how it works,
this is how you calculate your
net worth to just add the sum
of all your assets and
then subtract from it
the sum of all your liabilities.
But now let's dig a little bit deeper.
Because indeed, to really get
your personal finances right,
I believe it is crucial to also get
a good understanding of your cashflow.
And the way I look into this
is by looking into my income
my recurrent payments and my investments.
So what exactly does this mean?
So first of all, under income,
you have all the money
that you earn every month.
So for most people, this
would be a full time job.
Then you might also have some
income from a self employment.
Maybe you have some other side gigs,
some other side hustles that you have.
You might for instance, be renting out
a room in your home, at Airbnb.
So the sum of all of this is your income.
So what I do for instance,
for my self employment, is
that I have a new
specific tab where I model
all the income and the expenses
from my self employment.
And then I take the profit and
then link it into this line.
So for a self employment
like that, of course,
there should only be the profit.
But then of course, you
still have the problem
with the taxes, because
usually then the profit
from your self employment will
of course be a gross figure,
so it will be a figure before taxes.
And also on other income from
side hustles, for instance,
Airbnb, you will often
need to pay taxes on that.
So for these reasons,
I here included a line that
roughly calculates the value
of the taxes on this gross income.
So here you should include
your marginal tax rates.
So in my case, if you
already have a full-time job,
this would easily be
around 40% in Germany.
And then you deduct these
taxes from your income
to get a better understanding
of what your real after tax,
your net income really is.
And also see how this links
together with the liabilities,
with the accrued taxes,
because what I do here is
that I pretty much just add up the value
of all these taxes, up to the
current month in that year.
And this is then also the way how I come
up with these accrued taxes.
Then I then add in this liability
for the net worth calculation.
So this is the income.
So what's next that I have?
Next, I have an overview of
all my recurring payments.
And here of course,
what exactly this is, might
differ significantly by person.
Here, just a generic example,
you might have some living
expenses, so rent, utilities,
maybe some cleaning costs,
Then you might have some
services that you use.
So for instance, university fees,
some fitness center memberships, Netflix,
audible, some other
services that you might use.
So what you see here, what I do is,
that every payment, I
calculate as a monthly payment.
So if it's charged yearly,
for instance, university fees,
then I divide the figure
by 12, to understand really
what the average costs each month are.
And then I include
here, as an information,
whether this is a yearly
or a monthly charge.
And if it is a yearly charge,
in which month it is charged.
Just for me to not get
confused and to know when
these things will hit my bank account.
Next insurances.
So for instance, payments
for health insurance
or liability insurance that you have.
And then some other recurring
payments, for instance,
mobile phone, banking account
fees or anything like that.
So these recurring payments
are all the payments that
for sure will be deducted from
my bank account every month,
every quarter, every year.
So these are the things
that I cannot influence on a daily basis,
But of course you can influence
this in the medium term.
This for me already was a big revelation.
When I put this together
for the first time,
that I realized I had
all these little charges
from some memberships,
some other subscriptions.
I maybe signed up for
one or two years ago,
which I wasn't really using at the time.
So just transparency about
this is really crucial.
And then always asking
yourself whether you're
really still using this or whether
you can delete or cancel this.
So next section is the investment.
So what are all the payments related
to saving, related to investments
that you do every month?
And in this example,
you might pay an annuity
towards the real estate loan that you took
to buy the two apartments in Dusseldorf.
And then these would come
with some monthly payment
that will hit your bank
account every single month.
And then you also might
decide to participate
in a stock investment
plan, where every month,
a certain fixed amount is taken
from your bank account
and automatically invested
into certain ETFs or certain
funds that you've selected.
This for sure, is how I manage my savings,
how I manage my investments.
I do not ask myself at
the end of every month
how much money I have left,
what my possibilities are now
in order to do some investments.
But I have these fixed commitments
that are directly deducted
from my bank account,
directly after my salary comes in.
So it's pretty much a
given that I will invest
these amounts every single month.
And then it's up to me to figure
out how can I live with the rest.
Because of course, now what this means is
that the cash flow that you get here
on top by taking the income
then subtracting the recurring payments
and subtracting the investments,
this is all the money that is available
to you for all your daily
discretionary purchases.
So of course, this might
also be some important stuff
like food or clothing
or some other things that you
will need to pay every month
but it's just not automatically deducted
from the bank account.
But then this can of course also be
all these other fun activities,
like going on vacation,
going to a restaurant,
maybe having a great night
out with your friends.
In the end, all of this needs to be paid
via this free cash flow
that you have here.
So what I started to do
in the beginning is to
really track every month,
also all these expenses.
So by going over all my card
expenses, by really tracking
down every day, what
I spent the money for.
But frankly, then it took
me so long at the end
of every month to compile
this into such an overview.
At least for me, this
was not worth the time.
I'm happy with this
approach where now I just
have this number that I know is available
for me for all this discretionary spend.
And then of course, what
I did to challenge myself,
is that whenever this
number was increasing
to a level where I felt
I do not really need to
spend all this money
on discretionary stuff.
Then I was increasing my
monthly savings commitments,
I was increasing the amount
of my monthly stock investment
plans, but then over time,
of course you wanna have a share
of your investments as high as possible,
because this is what will influence
what will drive your net
worth in the longterm.
And then whatever is left,
this is then the amount
that you could use to live your life.
Of course, it's great to have a nice night
out to go to a nice restaurant.
So you need to find your personal balance.
You can do all of these things
to an extent that they satisfy
you, but also keep track
of your financial goals, to
keep your savings rate higher
and increase the net
worth of you over time.
So as promised, I will
give you the opportunity to
download this tracking tool
for your personal use as well.
There is a download link
below in the video description
to check it out if this interests you.
As always, if you have
any questions about what
we just discussed, feel free
to write me a comment below
in the comment section.
I will answer to every single comment.
And as you know, if you write a comment,
this also helps me with
the YouTube systems.
So every comment is warmly appreciated.
In addition to that, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe
to the channel to stay up
to date on all the content.
If you want to see even more from me,
I also have an Instagram,
my handle is @firmlearning.
I also have a mailing list,
you can sign up to that in
the video description as well.
And you can also reach out
to me on LinkedIn, again,
the link to that is in
the video description.
I now wanna say thank you to
all the members of the channel.
You are really making
a considerable impact
and contribution to my work,
this is very much appreciated.
If you wanna become a member as well,
hit the join button next to
the subscribe button to learn
about all the member only
perks that you get as a member.
So I release new videos
every single Saturday.
See you back again here
on this channel next week.
Looking forward to that,
until then, good weekend
and of course a great new
year, 2021 to all of you.
Cheers guys, this is
Heinrich, from Firm Learning.